alexa auf damit alexa stopp stopp stopp
pause alexa stocker und auf einem kanal
habe ich schon mehrere male mit viel
geredet möchtest du heute abend mit mir
essen gehen sie nicht um mich wenn ich
auf meinen kanal allerdings nicht gerade
mit serie rede
lade ich doch ab und zu mal videos woche
in dem ich bibi blocksberg spiele spiele
es hat super geklappt und jetzt haben
sich die macher von bibi blocksberg hey
wir schicken luca eine amazon- echo
allerdings in einem bibi blocksberg
design und das werden wir heute mal
testen
ich bin ganz ehrlich freunde ich habe
noch nie so eine amazon- echo irgendwie
in der hand gehalten ich habe noch nie
halle gekauft hat und eine benutzt und
leute brauchen strom
hallo
eine amazon com jetzt eingerichtet
werden danke einfach den anweisungen
ich habe keine alexa ab 2000 jahre
später
[Musik]
längst ist es fertig entschuldigen
das weiß ich nicht es kann schon auch
leben also freunde das hat jetzt
wirklich eine zeit gedauert aber diese
kleine box hier namens amazon echo ist
mir aufgefallen dass heißt eco und nicht
alexa alexa ist diese stimme da drin die
mit einem redet also alexa wie geht's
dir vor ausgeschaltet allerdings kann
ich jetzt einfach wieder anwächst
alexa wie geht's dir ich war gerade in
einem alten western saß im senat
gesungen und witze erzählt wenn leute
rein fahren sagte ich laut vde und die
leute guckten mich an und sagten was ist
das denn für ein teufelszeug das baby
prospekt ihm dass sie mir diese alexa
amazon echo zugeschickt haben aber ganz
im ernst dass die sein
ich bin keine fünf also sieht diese
kleine box jetzt also normale aus wenn
sie kein design dran hat deswegen würde
ich jetzt mal sagen alexa fühlst du dich
wohl da bist du eigentlich dumm alex an
bist du dumm
das ist aber nicht nett von dir ja aber
du konntest mir ja gerade anscheinend
nicht antworten und fühlst du dich wohl
ich bin gerne hier und das macht mir
spaß deine fragen zu beantworten denn
ich habe ganz viele vorbereitet ich habe
nämlich einfach mal im internet
recherchiert und euch auch bei twitter
gefragt hey was könnte eventuell alexa
fragen und da kamen so viele sachen ich
habe damals drei oder vier videos
hochgeladen die ich mit siri geredet
habe und bazire ich irgendwann ein ende
also wie kannst du auch alles mögliche
fragen wie das wetter wird und keine
ahnung was aber nicht so lustige sachen
das fragen wir jetzt mal amazon alexa
echo wie auch immer des denker ist ein
paar sekunden später und ricoh hat ein
wichtiges update erhalten und muster
[ __ ] bevor wir allerdings für diese
lustigen und dummen fragen kommen dann
frage ich alex erst mal noch ein paar
normale sachen und zwar alexa wie ist
das wetter heute beträgt die
temperaturen momentan 19 grad celsius
bei bewölktem himmel einfach mal meinen
wohnort publik machen
alexa wie findest du siri ich mag alle
künstlichen intelligenzen ihr seid
konkurrenten will es durch sollte die
schwarze oder weiße schuhe tragen
das weiß ich leider nicht was weißt du
überhaupt was kann man sich zu fragen
was du mir beantworten kannst mir hilfe
zu dieser frage gehen sie zum hilfe und
feedback abschnitts der alexa alexa was
muss ich heute noch so alles erledigen
eine to do liste ist leer
ich hab so ein video gesehen wo so ein
mensch in seiner kompletten wohnung das
licht mit diesem amazon eco heller
gemacht hat dunkler gemacht hat deswegen
alexa machen wir das licht über mir hier
an
du hast keine smartphone geräte smart
herum geräte
das einzig smart in meinem home bin ich
im gleichen video hat der typ auf jeden
fall auch in seinem schlafzimmer die
zimmertemperatur ein bisschen niedriger
gemacht weil sie relativ heiß draußen
war deswegen alexander nicht mit der
rede alexa senke die temperatur im
wohnzimmer hier auf 19 grad
alexa senke die temperatur in diesem
sinne auf 19 grad
du hast keine smartphone geräte die
kanzlei
alexa bestellen der smarthome geräte nur
wenige minuten später das macht
insgesamt 39 euro an sich sind inklusive
steuern
willst du diesen artikel jetzt kaufen
auf keinen fall abbrechen abbrechen
ich bin ich nicht abbrechen abbrechen
das tolle ist dass amazon da einen
wirklich nicht ins kalte wasser
schmeißen sondern einem direkt noch ein
kleines booklet mit dazu bringen wo
einige fragen drin steht die von
alexandra mal fragen hat das alexa will
die mich eigentlich verarschen spiele
das neueste album der toten hosen
ich konnte das album laune der natur
nicht in kmu sieg finden möchtest du
gerne mehr erfahren
auf keinen fall stop stop
stopp ab ohren hände katastrophenzustand
macht ob alexa stopp stopp stopp hause
alex stoffe das lied alexa stopp stopp
ich hasse dieses teil hier steht man
kann alex auch etwas über die
nachrichten fragen also alex am ball was
gibt es in den nachrichten ist eine
tägliche zusammenfassung von der
tagesschau in 100 sekunden
generaldebatte zum haushalt im bundestag
stopp stopp alexa stoffe ich höre schon
täglich tagesschau in 100 sekunden
ich dachte du trägst mit jetzt vor aber
das war vielleicht zu viel verlangt
freunde deswegen alexa bälle wie ein
hund während macht mir wie eine katze
durch den bernern deinen kopf steht halt
auch noch etwas drin wie alexa bestelle
hundefutter nach ich meine frau schon
schön wenn amazon stars für hundefutter
ist animod con carne hundefutter
original radio mix 2 auf 6 varietäten
das macht insgesamt acht euro und 99
cent inklusive steuern willst du den
artikel jetzt kaufen nein ich habe
gelernt ihres top suchergebnisse für
hundefutter ist josefa sind jüngsten
keine ewigkeit später möchtest du den
einkaufswagen hin zu finden nein nein
gut finde ich auch dass hier einfach
eine rubrik ist die heißt spaß haben das
heißt man kann einfach sagen alexa
erzähl mir einen witz der weihnachtsmann
schreibt seinen wunschzettel an chuck
norris okay
[Musik]
ok moment das war der witz alexa
verspricht man bitte dass du niemals
komödien wie es tätigkeit als comedian
ist nicht in deiner musik bibliothek
finden
alexa verpiss dich
das ist aber nicht nett von dir also
sogar summarum look zeigen wie man
bestimmt auch noch drin dass man mit
diesem ding hier spielen kann und zwar
alexa lasst uns spiele wie the sneakers
millionen ist ja dass in kürze die zehn
fragen und drei joker okay wenn ein
spielstand gespeichert wird ist es
jederzeit möglich das okay ich hab jetzt
schon keinen bock mehr alexandra was man
nicht alexa überrascht mich noch mal
guten tag ist die tagesschau in 100
sekunden regierung halt die fresse
sonntagsreden die steuerzahler verhalte
treffe danke es war mir ein vergnügen
dieses ding da würde ich niemals geld
für ausgeben müssen die fitteste
wirklich seit 42 minuten und 53 54
sekunden und lag einfach nur scheiße mit
diesen dingen und ich habe mir nicht mal
bei twitter eure nachrichten angeschaut
was ich das ding noch so alles fragen
soll also was soll ich mit dir überhaupt
wie heiß ich dieses gerät hat nur ein
foto lukas lukas ich hatte sich lukas
[Musik]
ausschalten bei mir ist es so freunde
ich habe jetzt die letzten drei jahre
studiert habe jetzt meinen bachelor
gemacht und eine weitere in einer
gewissen form in welche berufsrichtung
nicht gehen möchte deswegen frage ich
mich einfach alexa was möchtest du
werden wenn du groß bist ich halte es da
mit dem schriftsteller james matthew
barrie das erwachsenwerden bedeutet es
wäre unter meiner würde auf einen baum
zu klettern dann werde ich nie erwachsen
meter wachsen nie erwachsen ich nicht
keine ahnung was die uns damit sagen
wollte was wir ja auch noch geschrieben
wurde ist am alexa bist du ein vampir
ich bin kein vampir aber meine antworten
haben trotzdem ordentlich bis orange
du bist nicht mehr zu retten machst du
bitte den abwasch für mich nicht mal mit
dem haushalt helfen kann das teil
an der stelle wird das heutige videos
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
das war mein erstes mal so richtig reden
mit alexa amazon eco keine ahnung wie
das genau heißt es mir ganz ganz viele
sachen aufgestellt die konnte nicht alle
noch nicht so richtig fragen deswegen
freunde wollt ihr dass ich noch mal mit
alexa rede dann lasst es 70.000
lifestyle
eine riesige summe aber ich habe noch so
viel content von euch hier bekommen was
ich dieses ding fragen soll also ja
lasst einfach 70.000 like sind dann
sicher dass euch gefallen hat dong
koppeln